hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2016 crime and
thriller movie called hacker the movie
begins with alex denaliak a little
ukrainian boy migrating to canada with
his family in search of a better life he
resides in london ontario with his
parents
his mother works as a bookkeeper
assistant in a bank that also owns the
mortgage to their house
rarely has friends to hang out with alex
gets along well with his computer and
becomes interested in coding as he grows
up he works as a clicker providing
clicks to a website and saves his
paychecks for college admission
one night he overhears the arguments of
his parents who are both stressed due to
their economic situation and quietly
slips outside to buy coffee the tv at
the cafe shows news of a cyber attack
organized by darkweb an online criminal
organization led by a hacker named zed
he comes home the next day to find his
mother crying as she was fired from the
bank and due to not having a regular
income their house was also about to be
taken by the bank
alex immediately reveals all the money
he has been saving for college and gives
it all to his mother so they will not
lose their house
he contemplates how he can get more
money again than remembers about darkweb
he opens their website registers as a
regular user then finds out there are
several ranks to level up he needs to
get invited by another member or
complete an illegal task to prove his
ability he successfully steals the
credit card number of a bully at his
school then a dark web member roosevelt
contacts him to give him more access and
assignments
he sends alex several black market items
that alex can sell again to gain instant
loads of cash including laptops watches
phones and jewelry in just four weeks
alex is able to get back the thirty
thousand dollars he had saved up for
college he pays for his college bids
goodbye to his parents and moves to
toronto
college starts in january so he still
needs more money to fulfill his living
expenses
roosevelt already increased alex access
in darkweb so he can use credit card
numbers and fake ids for online shopping
and sell the items to potential buyers
at lower prices he tries to sell his
watches but has a hard time closing a
deal after going to several shops a man
who has been following him psy
approaches him and offers to help sell
the watches he successfully sells them
and gives alex a lot more money than he
expected alex is impressed so he works
together with sai alex is able to
purchase luxury items by carting then
psy sells them convincingly to many
customers
they are able to make sixty thousand
dollars in four months just before
alex's college term begins
alex watches another news about dark web
this time threatening banks with their
recent cyber attacks he figures that
college is not right for him and asks
psy for another help he wants to get
information from corrupt bankers as he
really hates banks due to them cutting
her mother's job and almost taking away
his house
psy enlists the help of his connections
in the hospitality industry who closely
interact with these bankers and are able
to obtain their credit card information
one day they visit a strip club in robin
the person in charge gives them an
infinity card left by a troubled
colombian customer
she says they can use the card as they
please
alex is hesitant to use the card at
first but manages to withdraw a load of
cash from it then makes a promise with
sai that they would never use the card
again
sometime later alex finds out that the
bank that fired his mom and owns the
mortgage to his house is on the
vulnerable list he plans a perfect
revenge scenario disguising as a british
man he goes to the bank and pretends to
open an account
he secretly plugs a usb drive into the
banker's computer which releases a virus
and almost gets away but the bank
security catches him
curtis the bank's chief of security
agrees to release him after being in a
long conversation which leaves psy
puzzled although failing to hijack the
bank alex's actions got praised on the
dark web and he got famous instantly a
girl kira reaches out to him and even
asks to meet him she seems clever even
psy agrees that she knows more about
hacking than alex so psy suggests that
alex asked her to work with them kira
provides them with more resources such
as credit card printing machines and
introduces them to bitcoin with kira
they are able to target bigger victims
and turn from online carding to real
carding they use various disguises to
buy luxury items from watches jewelry
and even a sports car kira even manages
to sell the items saying she has
connections from her uncle who are happy
to be their customers
alex is happy however sai is a bit
disappointed as he used to be the one
doing the selling one night kira says
that she wants alex to move to hong kong
with him saying it is the best place for
people like them
alex is reluctant at first but kira
insists that he think about it
alex meets up with roosevelt gives him
money as a token of gratitude and asks
if he knows anything about kira
roosevelt claims that he does not know
her which means she is actually not that
good of a hacker when alex asks if he
can meet zed roosevelt dismisses him and
leaves
alex kira and sai continue their
business and get to secure a huge deal
but psy argues with kira that this buyer
is too much of a risk
while they are arguing the client who
turns out to be a mob becomes impatient
and fires a warning shot then cancels
the deal
terrified by the incident alex agrees
that they need to move to hong kong
in hong kong they stay in a luxury hotel
and continue their business taking
several identities and buying luxurious
items by carting then selling the items
to potential buyers
however they start to get sloppy by not
checking the status of their many cards
one day a credit card they use issues a
pickup message which means the user has
reported it stolen so the authorities
try to catch them but they managed to
escape alex tells kira and sai that he
is starting to get bored and suggests
that they do something more impactful
such as causing chaos to send a powerful
message so that zed will notice them
psy is reluctant then he diverts the
conversation to celebrate his forgotten
birthday instead
at the club psy engages in a fight and
ends up detained in a jail with alex but
they are mysteriously released with the
help of kira's uncle the following day
psy goes out in the morning to withdraw
cash and gives it to alex as an apology
for last night's incident
turns out he uses the old infinity card
alex told him to not ever use again
alex becomes furious especially that psy
did not use any disguise and he kicks
psy out
after psy leaves alex and kira plan a
scheme to steal money from physical atms
across hong kong and leave a dark web
card after carrying out their actions
a total of 2.3 million are reportedly
stolen which catches the attention of
many news outlets
while alex celebrates the chaos that
they caused kira is hesitant and admits
that she wants to quit but alex refuses
suddenly a notification from zed pops up
he notices alex's actions and makes alex
his underboss
alex reaches out to zed wanting to talk
to him in person zed agrees to meet him
inside a guarded facility even agrees to
help provide resources for alex's
ultimate plan but warns them that if
they fail the plan they will die
after meeting zed alex receives a
voicemail from psy saying that he makes
his mind up wants to apologize and is
already back in their hotel room in hong
kong waiting for alex
however the mob catches up to psy first
and kills him
alex deduces that the infinity card user
had figured out about his stolen card
transaction and was actually going to
kill him and kira as well if sai did not
show up at the hotel alex and kira
immediately leave hong kong
news still reports about the recent
cyber attacks by darkweb which heavily
impact the stock market
fortunately the shaky market has started
to stabilize due to the federal reserve
chairman putting more money into the
economy the chairman is seen in a car
going to the bank while alex kira and
their team watch the surveillance
cameras and news outlets while keeping
close contact with zed
just before he arrives at the bank kira
hesitates and wants to walk away but
alex persuades her to complete this
mission together arriving at the bank
the chairman is walking from his car
when he suddenly gets shot and the
situation becomes chaotic
the stock market collapses and zed
already takes advantage of it by
regulating his stock shares in advance
knowing of the incoming collapse
he gains huge profit from it and
transfers alex and his team's pay
turns out the assassination is only a
prank to disrupt the stock market and
the real chairman is out hunting in the
woods
alex kira and the team quickly leave the
place but alex and kira are ambushed in
their car
alex is beaten up wakes up blindfolded
in an abandoned apartment but his
captors leave him after injecting him
unconscious
he escapes to bangkok where he already
plans to meet with kira if their plan
goes wrong
however kira never shows up and her
phone is unreachable so does zedd's
phone
alex goes to a local internet cafe and
finds out that the dark web site has
been suspended by the government zed has
been caught and kira has been shot dead
he refuses to believe the news about
kira but when he wants to search further
about her local cops come and arrest him
as he is using a fraudulent credit card
he is thrown into jail and becomes too
outrageous to accept his reality he even
attempts suicide but fails
eventually he accepts that he is alone
and starts living through his days
normally after two years he is
mysteriously freed by royal pardon and
walks outside puzzled he finds kira on
the sidewalk waiting for him explaining
to him that she used to work with the
fbi to catch zed so she needed to work
with him the fbi agent is curtis who
interrogated alex some time ago while he
attempted to hack into the bank's
security system the fbi plans a scheme
to catch zed in hong kong so kira needed
to persuade alex to come there the
cancelled deal with the mob was part of
the plan all along to scare alex to
escape to hong kong
after zedd was caught kira worked hard
to track alex and finally released him
alex is glad that kira is still alive
and they drive off together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching